it's been more than 20 years since this
hilarious sports comedy came out even
though critics of its day didn't love it
the replacements has been a movie
classic for many here's what members of
the cast have been up to in the time
since
beloved veteran actor keanu reeves
brought the world's most talented
barnacle scraper quarterback shane falco
to life in the replacements
after his turn as the downtrodden former
qb keanu reeves promptly disappeared and
was never heard from again oh wait that
didn't happen
in reality reeves has spent the two
decades since the replacements came out
becoming one of the biggest movie stars
in modern cinema and starring in more
blockbusters than we can count the year
after the replacements he starred as
lovable loser conor o'neal in the
heartstring tugging hardball in 2003 he
reprised his role as neo for not one but
two sequels to the matrix before playing
the title character in 2005's
constantine he played undercover cop bob
arctor in 2006's drug-fueled dystopian
rotoscoped philip k dick adaptation a
scanner darkly two years later took on
the role of clatto in the remake of the
day the earth stood still reeves made
his directorial debut in 2013 with man
of tai chi in which he also played
danaka mark a year later he launched the
massively successful series of john wick
movies starring as the titular assassin
in three films so far john wick chapter
4 is at the time of this video's release
currently filming
actor gene hackman took on the role of
demanding but understanding head coach
of the washington sentinels jimmy
mcginty or as shane falco called him
that old coach from the 80s a year after
the replacements hackman appeared in the
crime rom-com heartbreakers alongside
sigourney weaver jennifer love hewitt
and ray liotta he played william the
unwitting mark of a marriage con in 2001
he starred as royal the father of the
eccentric tit chiller family in wes
anderson's quirky comedy the royal tenon
bombs co-starring ben stiller gwyneth
paltrow owen wilson and luke wilson that
same year hackman teamed with owen
wilson again for the war thriller behind
enemy lines
playing navy admiral leslie reigart he
was the commanding officer of the uss
carl vinson whose fighter pilot was shot
down on a routine reconnaissance mission
in 2003 he starred alongside dustin
hoffman rachel vice and john cusack in
the legal drama runaway jury adapting a
john grisham novel
in his final film role before retiring
hackman starred in the 2004 political
comedy welcome to mooseport with ray
romano he played former united states
president monroe eagle cole who gets
drawn into an increasingly silly
campaign to become mayor of a small town
in maine
head cheerleader annabelle farrell was
brought to life by actor brooke langton
not only is she an amazing on-field
performer she's a huge football fan even
if shayne's entire team turned against
him he would always have one true
believer on the sidelines
two years after appearing in the
replacements langton showed up in many
guest roles on popular tv shows like
weeds in 2005 and monk in 2006.
langton reunited with the replacement's
co-star orlando jones for the b horror
movie primeval in 2007 playing a
journalist who travels to burundi to try
to capture a giant man-eating crocodile
later that year she joined the main cast
of nbc's crime drama life playing the
role of constance griffiths she's the
attorney who proved the innocence of the
wrongly convicted lead character
detective charlie crews played by damian
lewis
in the years since langton has appeared
in a few other popular series and films
like the death in 2015.
in 2018 she took on the recurring role
of lieutenant maddy rawlings on tnt's
action drama series the last ship for
five episodes working alongside the rest
of the crew of the uss nathan james to
try to find a cure for the pandemic that
ravages the planet
actor orlando jones was a perfect choice
for the role of less than sure-handed
wide receiver clifford franklin he might
have had some serious wheels and major
breakaway speed but he sure didn't have
the mitts and dexterity required to haul
in a pass with any consistency
jones kept plenty busy following his
turn as franklin a few months after the
replacements was released he took on
multiple roles in the faustian comedy
remake of bedazzled there elizabeth
hurley plays the devil enticing brendan
fraser's hapless character to sell his
soul
the next year jones played community
college professor harry block and the
underrated sci-fi comedy evolution
fighting an alien invasion a year later
he appeared as the digital artificial
intelligence librarian box 114 in the
time machine a loose adaptation of the
classic h.g wells novel of the same name
in 2003 jones joined gene hackman as
part of the cast of runaway jury in
addition to his work in feature films
jones has enjoyed plenty of success on
the small screen including his turn as
captain frank irving on the supernatural
procedural sleepy hollow he also nabbed
a recurring role as mr nancy aka the
tricker god anansi on the popular neil
gaiman series american gods
kicker nigel gruff as played by actor
rhys ephons isn't exactly what you'd
call athletic though it's clear his
liver gets a regular workout the former
soccer striker is more what you'd call
wiry three months after the release of
the replacements ephons appeared
alongside another talented cast taking
on the role of adrian one of the sons of
satan and adam sandler's little nikki in
2001 he took on the role of icky a club
owner who also deals in drugs and guns
in the 51st state the film starred
samuel l jackson as a revolutionary drug
chemist and was alternately titled
formula 51. in 2010 gefonz had an iconic
turn as xenophilius lovegood publisher
of the quibbler and father to luna
lovegood in harry potter and the deathly
hallows part 1.
two years later he played dr kirk
connors mentor to peter parker played by
andrew garfield and eventual reptilian
villain in the amazing spider-man
ephons also enjoyed a recurring role as
mycroft holmes brother to sherlock
holmes played by johnny lee miller on
the modern american crime procedural
elementary
actor michael jays portrayed defensive
back earl wilkinson who went to prison
for allegedly beating up a cop naturally
he mixes well with danny bateman as such
wilkinson wears a tinted visor on his
helmet and plays under the alias ray
smith this is so no one's aware that a
convicted felon has been released by the
governor to serve as a replacement
player during the strike
jace is perhaps best known as julian
lowe a uniformed police officer and
member of the main cast of the shield
fx's gritty crime drama he appeared in
all 88 of the series episodes across its
seven seasons portraying a cop enduring
the inner conflict of his homosexuality
brought about with his devout christian
faith lead character vic mackie is aware
of julian's sexual orientation and
blackmails him to keep a secret
jace's final credited role was recurring
character tyrell on the crime drama
southland in 2014 according to cnn jace
was arrested and charged with homicide
in the fatal shooting of his wife april
jace having reportedly dialed 9-1-1
himself
michael jace was convicted of
second-degree murder in may 2016 for abc
7 which reported the jury deliberated
for fewer than three hours before
reaching a guilty verdict a month later
jace was sentenced to 40 years to life
in prison he is currently incarcerated
in california state prison and will be
eligible for parole in 2039 according to
the california department of corrections
and rehabilitation
if there's one thing for which
quarterback shane falco can be grateful
it's that linebacker danny bateman
played by john favreau is on his team
this means that he's only on the
receiving end of his crushing tackles
when bateman forgets that he's not
supposed to hit players wearing red
jerseys in practice opposing qbs had
better look out because he hits hard and
fast despite having only played college
football as a walk-on the year after the
replacements came out favreau wrote and
directed his first feature film made in
which he also starred he appeared
alongside vince vaughn as a mediocre
boxer who gets involved in low-level
organized crime two years later favreau
took on the role of franklin foggy
nelson in the much-maligned ben affleck
starring marvel comics movie daredevil
of course in 2008 he helped launch the
marvel cinematic universe as harold
happy hogan tony stark's driver
bodyguard and best friend and iron man
favreau appeared in all three iron man
solo films as well as directing the
first two
in addition to helping to mentor peter
parker tom holland in the mcu's two
spider-man movies favreau has continued
to direct and produce helming the
live-action remakes of disney's the
jungle book and the lion king if all of
that wasn't enough he is also the
creator and serves as show runner of the
mandalorian the star wars streaming
series on disney plus
according to coach jimmy mcginty tight
end brian murphy played by david denman
would have been drafted in the first
round if he hadn't been born deaf
despite living with such a limitation
brian manages to excel as a member of
the replacement washington sentinels
look at it this way you'll never be
called offsides on an audible
denman's turn as brian was his first
appearance in a feature-length film in
2001 he took on the role of lance the
gay bartender at the fictional alaskan
ski resort of bull mountain in the
snowboarding comedy out cold denman
played bully don price who beats up
protagonist edward bloom in tim burton's
2003 fantasy film big fish
dinman's most recent film role came in
2020's greenland for which he took on
the character ralph bento who kidnaps
john garrity's son nathan
denman has also enjoyed memorable small
screen roles including appearing as ed
brooks the adulterous love interest of
julia braverman graham that was on the
nbc family dramedy series parenthood he
also recently took on the role of frank
sheehan ex-husband to the title
character and the acclaimed hbo limited
series mayor of east town
acionamine took on the larger than life
role of jumbo fumiko a member of the
replacement washington sentinel's
offensive line he is a former sumo
wrestler which makes him an expert at
pushing people around as coach jimmy
mcginty says in the world of
professional football that translates to
past blocking fumiko is also the big
hero of the bar fight having sat on
wilson's head and his eye becomes a
popular rally and cry among the team
unfortunately he commits a holding
penalty when shane falco and probably
runs the ball in for a touchdown on the
field goal attempt during which nigel
gruff was nearly forced to blow the kick
on purpose
yonamine's role in the replacements is
an instance of art imitating life prior
to his appearance in the movie his
feature film debut the hawaiian-born
actor worked in japan as a sumo wrestler
according to hawaiian outlet midweek
to date yonamine has only appeared in
two additional films according to imdb
in 2003 he appeared in laura croft tomb
raider the cradle of life he was an
imposing member of the criminal
organization chaeling which was hired by
dr jonathan reese to retrieve the map to
the mystical object in 2005 yonamine
appeared as a sumo wrestler in memoirs
of a geisha
according to midweek he's continued
acting by appearing in commercials and
worked security at the courthouse in
pearl city oahu hawaii
jamal jackson as played by actor faison
love is a bit of a hothead he and his
brother andre are a formidable pair of
guards that coach jimmy mcginty recruits
back into football after they retire and
become actual bodyguards after the bar
fight that unites the team the brothers
realize it's their job to protect
quarterback shane falco on and off the
field so when the striking players
harass quarterback shane falco in the
parking lot a second time jamal pulls a
gun and shoots eddie martell's car
multiple times
a year after appearing in the
replacements love showed up in various
films including couples retreat with
co-star john favreau who also co-wrote
the film he took on the role of shane
the recently divorced guy with a wild
20-something girlfriend in 2003 he
appeared in the charming will ferrell
christmas comedy elf also directed by
favro as wanda he's the manager of the
gimbals department store who sends buddy
played by farrell into a frenzy by
announcing that santa claus would be
coming in addition to finding steady
work as a character actor in films love
also appeared in nine episodes of kevin
hart's b-e-t reality tv parody real
husbands of hollywood he played a
fictionalized version of himself in the
show's first fifth and sixth seasons in
2018 love joined the cast of step up
high water a drama series based on the
popular step up movies as al baker love
appeared in the first two seasons that
aired on youtube red step up was picked
up for a third season by premium cable
network stars
actor michael talafero took on the role
of andre jackson the larger brother to
jamal who is a bit more level-headed
though just as protective of shane falco
once the team comes together in that
memorable parking lot scene andre
reveals that he's pretty fond of the
smell of that wild yam that annabelle
farrell gave shame to soothe the sore
muscles
what's that smell
wild yet
that's nice
following the replacements telephero's
next film appearance came in the
independent crime drama blue hill avenue
he took on the role of simon an
adrenaline-fueled criminal who with his
three friends is one of the biggest drug
dealers in boston in 2002 telefaro
appeared as inmate little joe in the
crime thriller half-past debt helping
steven seagal's fbi agent character
rescue a kidnapped supreme court justice
on alcatraz for 2004's dance film you
got served he played emerald he was the
drug lord for whom lead characters elgin
and david work in order to pay for the
little saints to enter their street
dancing battles talifaro's final film
role came as brian smith in the crime
musical a day in the life a film that
was released in 2009 a little more than
three years after his death in 2006.
as the tampa bay times reported he died
on may 4th at the age of 44 after
suffering a stroke near his home in los
angeles california
troy winbush brought to life pious
running back walter cochran cochran is
one of the replacement washington
sentinels with some actual experience
playing professional football though not
much
he played one game in the pros and blew
out his knee pretty much ending his
career or so he thought when given a
second chance at playing football he
just wants to score one touchdown
thankfully he manages to do just that
though he blows out his knee again in
the process
cochran notably makes shane falco
promise to finish what he started we
assume he's telling him to win the game
one of wimbush's next feature film roles
came in the 2002 thriller john q in
which he appeared as expectant father
steve smith he is one of the character
john archibald's hostages
denzel washington's role is of a
desperate father who seeks to get his
son on the recipient list for a heart
transplant
in the years since winbush has found
consistent work as an actor taking on
guest roles in various popular tv series
he's appeared in shows ranging from
police procedurals like ncis to dramas
like saving grace he's also had a
recurring role as officer pachinski on
the popular sitcom the goldbergs wimbush
recently appeared in season one of the
wilds the streaming drama from amazon
studios as fbi agent dean young
ugg eddie martell played by brett cullen
where to even start with this guy he's a
prima donna ending the final game before
the players strike with a giveaway slide
instead of going for the win martel is
also an unrepentant jerk who has his
fellow striking players flipped shane
falco's already beat up truck in the
parking lot in reality we hope cullen is
a decent person and we've got no reason
to believe otherwise though he's played
some other sketchy characters in the
years since
starting in 2005 he took on the
recurring role of goodwin stanhope one
of the others sent to infiltrate the
group of surviving passengers of oceanic
flight 815 on lost cullen also appeared
as the creepy adulterous congressman in
2012's the dark knight rises though that
wouldn't be his last role in a dc comics
batman film having seemingly perfected
playing an entitled jerk he took on the
role of thomas wayne the father of the
future caped crusader bruce wayne who's
also maybe maybe not the father of
arthur fleck played by joaquin phoenix
he is of course the joker in the 2019
film joker cullen also had a recurring
role on the blacklist beginning in the
finale episode of season six he also
appeared in season three of true
detective as the eventual arkansas
attorney general gerald kent
veteran actor jack warden brought
washington sentinel's owner edward
o'neill to life he's an old school kind
of guy and he hilariously yells at eddie
martel from his luxury box
he declares the cocky quarterback to be
a wimp after his give up slide at the
end of the final pre-strike game though
he uses a different word altogether when
courting jimmy mcginty to be his new
head coach
in set negotiations he promises to give
coach mcginty full control of the team
spoiler alert he breaks that promise
after martell tells megenti that o'neal
will fire him when shane falco shows up
during half time of the final game the
furious coach yells something that
elaborates on the troubled history
between the two it won't be the first
time
the replacements marked warden's final
film appearance as he retired from
acting citing concerns of declining
health he turned 80 the year the film
came out as the bbc reported in 2006
warden died at age 85 after weeks of
poor health his manager had told the
outlet that warden had suffered from
heart and kidney problems prior to his
death
check out one of our newest videos right
here plus even more looper videos about
your favorite movies are coming soon
subscribe to our youtube channel and hit
the bell so you don't miss a single one
you